>> IRIS CHAN, AUTHOR OF "THE
SP
OORFS: ANIRHANGAUTH
R"T
HE NE APOF: KIANNGETH
OTFO
RGLON TEHOOFUSCAT  WOR WLD
II
OUN  W,"HEU D DIYOT RSTHINK
ABINWRT IT BTHG ISK?OO
ue>>
GLL: stWEOEIT,  GCKS BATH A
NG
I LOGOAY W.
ANMEARI , LEOUD NEABTHT IS
T ENEVT AS IEN WTL L AITD,CHE IK
WRBUREI IDLYAL DINT N'THABK OUT
ING E BOOK UIL II
FI
NISH MY RST ONE,ADTH "REA
COC
A
IAFOLIRNWAHA TT VO SDETODTE
PR
NGERESVIHIHE T ORY IS
ENEVT.
T>>HA WAS "THE IN MOF
ANKI
? QNGET
>>
TH ATE  'SON TOFHE EAGRSTTE
AT OTICIESDWOF RLORHI ST YINO
DE
OMBCEERF93 17 T,HE PAJASENE
TEP TOINE THL PICATANA COFHI,
ICWHTHWAH S  MEN KANDG INAN
WI T SINIXOEI TGHWE SEK EYTHH
RETCBUHE,DPE RA DAN EDRTTOUR
DSNDHUREOUF  OTHOFNDSAS  INCHEES
VIS.AN
300 00OPPELE MAULTILYTE EDDI
RIDUNG MTHISE SAASCREYD ANTH
PE
RA ADN MAESTIDTE 0020,0 TO
W,08000URENOM DISG INTH ODPERI.
W>>HYTH ISUCEER SA
PASCDIRETWY NCBENEE 0020,0 AND
00,0?
IT 'S TEOFICDIN FFTUL TO
CEE N AITHNUACEXT ER.
MANYOME  WENERANLURECTTOT
MECO OUT WTHITH E S FACT TATHE
MEI
>>
'M I INLOOKAGATG  PE9  5DAN
S ERTHE'LEGEA NTNMAHE  REBY THE
FMENA O OKO.
WHO  HE?
W  HL,E SWAA CTOR.
HE'S A ORDOCTNO W  TBUBACKIN
HE3719, ONAS W OF E SOIELDRS
O DITMMTE ATESCIROTIANN  IN
KI.
>>HE'SRE A MI' INGOG TO
ADRE MESOHEINTHG   IRENA MT
T HAVE MEU YOT HIEMM
>>O.
.
NO
ASTH W TAK FENMRO AN ARCLTIE,
ET BUTHSTOR S STJUSO
CO
LIELNGI HA TT DHATO  ITT PU
IN
OKY  MBO.
OR B>>EFREIE TH, TE MLLE
HEATWH T ITO SRY
S.>>
EL WWA HL,E INS  -- AREWE
LKOUG AB THT EST TY ORINHE
ARTICLE LFITSE?
L W>>EL'SHE TREA -RISHNE
->>
HEL WL,A E'S CTOROW AND
FEELS  SOTERRLE WBO AUTATH
HESOID D, E HA TPU ETH
ESCTPIURF O --THE SGUES SO
MEOF
HE ATRIEOCITHEINS  TAITI
ROOM OFIS H .INCLIC
DANENPATI  OTSFHIS CAN SEE
ATINDIE D INAN N KG.
LETME  READ A TTLILE BIOM
ATE  HOUAVT GOINUR YOBOOK.
I REMEMBEREI B DRIN IN
TRG K ONA PATH ATTHADEN BE
CLEARED HROTHUGSPI LEOF
OUTHNDS D NDOUTHSASOF
TEAUSLGHDRE BOES.
WILD DOGS WERE AWGNIN ATTHE
ADS SHLE AWE STPED AND
ALLPUED RO GUPNE COFHISE
ERISPRONOFOUS T ACHE T B
K.TH
TENHENEJAPA SEFICE
PA SEPOD F STTE ORA CMYOUGE.
HE
UNSH THEAEDSHISW DOR, SPAT ON
A
IT NDWITH A DDSUENMI TYGH
INSWG HE BROUGH IT DOWN  THE
NECKF A CHINE ESY BOCOWENGRI
BEFORE US.
THE HE WAD ASCUT CLN OF AND
TUMBLED AYAWON   EOUGRP  ETH
BO PESLUMD FORWARD, OOBLD
URSPNNGTI ITW O EAGRT GUINSHG
FOUNINTAS FR  TOMHECKNE.
TH
ERFIOFCE GGSUITEESD TA KE THE
HE
E  HADOM ASA SO.ENUVIR
I ERMEREMBSMING PRASDLOUY
OK
TOSWHI S D D ORANBAN KLING
LE
Y'D UYO -- YOU KNOW,USBV OIOLY
TH
TH ISBOYOEDER
WH
DIY DUYO TPUIS TH IN E?THER
I
>>D AN WTESH TO PEOPAT LETH
TH
PA EJASE IESOLD RS IWEREALNC
TEKAD TO ITPLENVIOL.CE
S ISTH IATNO  ORY ASATTH W AN
OLCI EDINNTDE
.TH
H WISASNGPEAPNIUGHR TOUTHO
N NDNG AHE TY--  EYTH
RESSMAACLEPED OPTHLL A Y  EWATO
THE TACAPI ANL DTHEY EVEN
HENGIL KLISTON CTE SRDIN OER
NSITE JAETH NEPASE
LDRORSIE FINFEM ELCTREG LUTAN
MM INCO TTIITNGSEHE ROAT.TICIES
G  AE CTPIURRE OF
RPATORALNSIO GON E THENGYATZ
VER.
THE BIG E.ON
E ERDID UYO FICTHIPIURE
THIPICTUR TE T HAONME
FROM -AT- TH'S  Y--EAH,SHA TT'
A
PA CONDESRRPOO T ENWHOKTO
ATE.CTPIUR
WAATTH INRES PRD TEER SINEV
ALOT
BLR HEPUNSATICIO.
SOEA'SIT RYLL -- MI'TE INLLG
YOT' TU,HA NOS TTHE MO
UEGRPIMESO THURCTE E.ER
YO
MAY T NTWA W  STOHOETH
AU
ENDICE S TE OMOF OTHS THAT
ARE  INBO MY.
>>WELL, ACTULY, I INTHK WE DO
WANT  STOE W HOTHCTUR SO
THEY CANEE -I MEAN, NOT ATTH
CTTH OE,N HE EOTDE RSI IF WE
CA PIN CK ON THE HER
DESI.
ATTH CTPIGHE URRIE.THT ER
AT
TH --  ATWH'SIS?
>>
HE T ONE  ONETH LEFT?
>>HT RIGE.ER
>> OH, RIGHT, THAT'S A MBNU OF
HEADS THAT HA JUST BEEN PUT
OU
OWU YOKNTHISAS THEIC TYP
SCENANINE  NIN KG, BEHEADISNG,
ENTHME SOMETIEYS THDWO UL PUT
UPADHES OSON  PE LTSIKHA TT
CTRNUNE DETHEA.
THA LEOP ULCOD UNDETAND
T ATWH IULD  IFKELI EY TH
NTD TO JSIREST.APAN
>>RE WNDHEHIAS W T?DOS NE
S T>>HI SWADO NE IN NAN NGKI,
T OU TSOHR--OUGHT N, M IEA
THUTUGROHO, HI CNALYTUACAL.
>>HAT ES WATHHI ORSTY WOFHYW
E
THPANE W CE ERININNAHI
IN NKING?
EL>> WL,IN 1937JATH, E NEPASE
UNOR OANPPNITUTY TOEOVPROK
WAR THWI A,CHIN ANDIT
TLLCAEDHE RCMAO PAO OLEDG
NTCIINDE.
D ANWEPROBONLYAB D 'TVEHAOO T
MUCHET DL --E TDON' OOVEHA T
MU
E TCHIM IN GTOO T, TTOHAUT B
'SLAA  KTOD TEINLL F AUCA-SLET
R DAN THE SEPAJANENV IEDAD
AIANSHGH IN  ETHLLFA OF93 1
7,AN
THD E -- EYTH DHA INORIGLYAL
OU TTHT AT W WHEARAKLDOU TE
ONACPLE LY--LY ONRE EMOHSNT,
TH
UG TEYHOY THTHECO DUL RNQCOUE
PAJAINN  AMA ERTT OF NTMOBU HST
H
OENNE  TTBALEONE  ONE
CH
CIESINE TY, SH DGHANAIGGRAED
FLOHA TT E , NGTHSEPAJANE
WENXRE AOUSIO TIN  MAKEAN
E AMEXPL C TOFHEITY.
EYEAREWE F  YRSOUDAN
ATUSFRTR AEDND ATTHHEAS W TO MOD
ATHE RSLDSOIEWE REIN  AS
EYTH HEMARCD OMFR GHSHANAI TO
NANKING.
>> WREHE IAISINNKING ?HI CNA
>>NKNAG INIS TUSIINEDAT BE AND
T
OFGT YHEANER RZEIV.
MAYBE WE C SHAP AOW MIG RHT
NO
W.
LL >>I'ITIN FD
.GO
HEAD
>>ON'SIT LYA W SMILE AWAY
LL
AY.
>> TS THO SWSSA MHEASECR
ONCALOTI
.>>
S HA TT'GHRIT.
ANLD WAIOUE B ONTH ASCOT
OF INA, AN THIS --AND THEN
NA IKINNGRTFUHENDINR LA.
D TH CITY ISGHRITIN THE --
LIKE SITUATEDIG RHT AT THE BEND
OF WHE TREHE VERISECOR URS,OU Y
N
, OWTOETHORTHND THEN
TULOTOS  FW SWATORD COTHE T.AS
SOTHHE WN NEJAE PA EPSWT
WAINNAS NKY  TG,HEDHA -- LAL
HEYADDOO T S WA CIENTLERC I
OM
FR OHR TEEERTH REDI,IOCTNS
CA
BEEE USTH VER SE RMFOED
NA ARATUL RRBAIER.
HE BEUYO TOEN  NAINNKG?
>>TESOABLU.LY
M H>>OWTIYAN S?ME
>>ALTULYIN MME THSU OERF
95 IHEAS W TR REFO  Y--W KOUNO
VER FOSEWELRA SEK, LYTUACAL.
ST
JUTINE O .ME
>>
ND A'SWH ATYO UR RSPEALON
NN CTNEIOKI NTOAN?NG
>>YL,EL MTHERWA S RN W
ATTH EAAR.
ANIL FMYAMALACY TULY -- MY
ARANGRDPSETSEN UDTO VE LIIN
NKNA
TH WERE ALMPAT OSSEDRATE
FORVE ORSHFOY TLBE TREHERE
RESSMAACF.TS IEL
COU Y MEREMB TERHEFI TRS
ME Y HED AR OFRAE THPE
NKNA
YEAAS IH, WTL L AITGIRL
I N'T MEREERMB TLEXACY HO WOLD
WAI T S,BU I ST HE ENBEIN
GRE SCOL ATHT TIE ME.
MY
NTPA REWES RE OFESSO AT
E SIIVUNER OF IL, NOLIISDAN
TE WE LL AG INMEHEUTBO T
IN
CHSE T FORKI NHEAN
NGMA
ACRE
EYTHDAI ATTH E KIHALLG D
ENINO TNS --E TEINNSIN
NAATG INTHIVHE T RER, ETH
VERIR TELILLRAY RAN D REWITH
BL
R D OOFOYSDA.
D EY IDSA TOPT HAPEERLE W
EBE
GIN EDHACKPIO ECESAN, D AT
E TI,  WTHISAS S T--HI WAS
VEFOAR HD MER  TO VIIZSUALEY
D AL RE LY TNTWAEDNLEO AR
RE AUT IT.
I WE TO NT THECA LOL YBRLIAR
S
TOF I I CONDD ULFIINNY ATH
GAB
, T OUITD THSNE ERWA A'T
LESINGOO BK  ISENGLONH  .IT
ULCO'TDN  FINDANHIYT.NG
HA WYODIT D UDO  XTNE?
W>>ELHI IL, TA ANKS ILCHD I
DI
TH'TDN OUK INABORITT  F
AN
20HEOTR .EA YRS
TH
ORAE PEF GNKNAINID DTN'
TRY ONE  MNTFELI U--
TIWAL I RR SMANDDIE A  IWAS
G VIN SAN BARRABA
D A FILMMAKER IOFEND IN ME
LDTHE AT  T HHEADEN FWORIDS
OWHHAHEARTHAT OPPEE
WEBE- D EN LMFIGIN ARE
DOY NTMEARE ONTHRA PE OF
NAING, ATT BUTHHE THY AD
PR
LEOBMSNGCUSERIINFU NDIG
FOINTHK RIDIR STONTIBUSEEC BAU
J
OFEANAPES INEUEFLNCINIS TH
UN
COATY TRTHAT 'SWH PIYQU M
TEIN ASTGA
.
TECAD THE FILMMARS AND
LKEMO  TTHND A ONE  OFTHEM
NCNGTO O FRO EDDEUC ETH
CUDOMENTY INHE NE AM TOFHE
PEMERER -LDTO -EM ROPER TOLD ME
T
THWAHI TS S INCHEES TIACSMVI
THIEVENT  AND I WAS
INEDRESTOUI  SH CLD TTAONCTS
RT
PAULICAR ORNIZAON, LLCAED
THE LI CEORTHE
ERPRES OTIVAONTHF HTRE UTOF
WORLD  WAR.II
I OUR TNSIS, UTTHARTULAR
GA
ORONZANITIAS W HOINSTGA
ENNFCOER ON E RA PEOF
NKECING  D19BEEMR .94
SO WCEIN INAS I SAA RBBAAAR
AN
THD EENNFCOERCE TOWAS E B
HEKUN I RPETI ,NO JUSDREOVLD
UP AND NDTEED THE EVENT.
NOW, WHAT I SN'T EPEDAR FOR
S WACTE THFATHHA TT  HEYAD TPU
ER
ST-SEDID--  STPOER-ZESID
PI
URCT OESSOF ME OTHF E
ROCIESND A W I ASEISENG
TH
ESEPI  FURCTES TORHEY VER
FIT TIME.
ANDI WAS --I  MEREERMB ILT FE
TCKMY SMACH AND IN, MEA I
REALLY   OUTHT GHAT  ONEINPOT
THI  ATULWODHA VE  TOGO MEHO
CABEU ISEO AS W SL.IL
OWU YOKN
?AN
I SOREO EDLV T SDOHIOMET.NG
GHTHI OUT,TH WA ISS SOBA DAND
YE
ONNOT   EHAD ILSTL WRTEITAN
BOOK BOAAUT IT.
SOI  FIITREGUD AS W METITO  KETA
TIITINIA.VE
I W>>HOISS THOM WP AN UREHE?
>>
ELE OWSHIN-WG.
I>>SESH IVALE?
YSH, ISE .
>> A WS HAT'ORE THST>>
WELL,BA CKIN  SH3719, WAE AS
EENTEAG -- A WIFE  OFA
CICHTENI WAN D FLED  TFROM
HE
NK ONAING ON TOP OFA
TRAISHANN D LEWAE S IN BFTEHIND
E CI.
END E DEUPD  FG HTIGINFOFTH
REE SOLDWHRSO TRIED TO RAPE
HER.
STEYTH HEBEABD MOR R 3THE AN
0TI
S.ME
>>OEREHE DSH SE VELINO W?
IN G.NKNAIN
>>
DIDYO  ULKTATO  R?HE
>> SYE,ID. DI
H>>OWNGLO?
IO KEPO TR R HEFOLVESERA
HO I AS,NDLIEL FT IM AKE TE
AV
TRER BSASE WTH IS
E CTPIURR OFHEWHENHE S SWA
AISTLLGEEE TNA
D ENWH M I F HETERE ACE, FTOAC
E
SHSWAAL STMO 80 S YEAROLD.
DOHA WT  ESSHE OKLO KELI NOW?
WE, SHS E'STILA L VERY--
SHA S VE NITYCE N.WOMA
SHE'S VERY STRG.ON
ON TOFHE ROSTESNGT MEWOIN
EVAVHE . MERET
SHSE'  --WELL SHE HAS SOMA NY
INWROWESKL N TTH ATVEY HEHA
VECORED UPHE T, CA SRSTBU WHEN
SHE SWA YOUNGER, T SHENRSCA O
R ERCEFA WIBHOE RR.LE
IN A>>GASHE SST BEABD 37
MES WITH BAYOTS
TRRT'COECT.
C YOU MBREMEYT ERANNGHI
BOSEEL A UTETH Y?STOR
ER SWAE  SHAT TH ETI SMEHE
WA
BESTS AB
>>ASHE WG ID HIN TINHE
INNAATRNIOTYSAL FE WZO NECHHI
A
S  LUTNERA NEZO ORGABYZENID
TH
FOE RSIGRENEF ONANKTOG IN
T PRECTHEM FM THE JA.NEPASE
D PRL'L LYAB LKTA REMO
THOUABT  ATTELAR.
T ATHE T TIME, SOA IELDR DHA
S
HIE EY HONER.
WH HE DONTWE TO WNINE TH
BA
MESENTSHERWHE  ESWA DIHI,NG
THETOEDRI  PE HER,BU TE SH
EDSORELVO  TGHFIT E TOTH DEATH
TONTRE PVEBERO FM G RAD.
SO Y CKLUILWAE SHERBIS GGHA TN
HE
SOAS W, WHHA TT  HENE
LUI  -ED- WHESGUS CA HENE ME
HER R, SHEPPIKRIED HIS
TYOBANE  TFROMAT SHEHESHANH D E
THREESI W GU HE BACK NSAGAIT
E
THANLLWA DSH  ESTJU TESTARD
APTHG INWIIM H.
SH
DENE DEUP US  GINHIM AS A
MA
HULDSHN IE AIN TST THEWO
HERSLDSOIE WHO RE TINRYG
B  STOTAD R HEANTOTPREC, YOU
KN
M,, OWHI ET BUSH WAS INUSG MHI
AS
A O IE TPREVOMT ENFR
G TTGEIND ASSLHE.UP
>>HODID RVE SHSUE?IV
>>L,EL RVE SHSUUSEDIV J
T
RELY.
BAONE NEYOT STHEBEABD GHR RIINT
ETH H OMSTACED ANSH EVLYTUENAL
LO
B HSTERY.AB
BU
SHT E TEFAINSHAND D WAE
SAL
STMO RIBUED ALEABLHER
FA  WLYHO'TDIDNE RALE SH
ILS WASTIVL AL
E.BU
T SOMEEON NOTIDCE E SBBBULE
OFBLOOD FRNGHI FROM HE RUTMOH
D ANEYTH SHEDHER TO ETH
HOSPITAL WHERE THE AMERICAN
,CTDOOR BEROSO WRTIL SN,AVED H
ER
.
N, SSHE' NOW 80ME SO ARYES
OLD.
ENTA LKTO HE ,R HOW NYMA
METIS DDI DYSOBOEL ASKER
ABOUT VEISTH OYETHR E S?AR
, >>OHK THI INREHEOTR SRTPOER
D
HA WLKTAEDR.H ITHE
M
I'TNO  ALRELYRESU
>>
TAOU Y LKABT YOUR DA BEGIN
RNERR EATHE.
ATWH A UTBOYOUR GRENDPANAR?TS
VEY L,EL M'STHMOER NTPARE
WE
REIN  NKNAG IN 3719.
ME G, ANMYTHNDRAFA AERUACTLLY
S IN THE CITASY  TES JANE
REBOMBG IT.
AN
D ERTHSTS E'JUN  AINLEEDCRIB
OR
STOWOFY  HHE TY WE MOALST
SEPARARED TEFOR DUNGTH E
CHTHS AT OWFOLLED E THMASS
EV
ONUAACTI
>>PPT HAHAFTEDEN AAT ERTH?
MEOWI , KN- - I RE THE
ST  BY,UTLLTE USRE MO OUABT
.T
>>O
K.YO
SEU E, WH TENHE FHTIGGIN
A
SHESHANGI LATE  JU
ST
CCABEMEAR TMYFARA GNDTHER
AT HIS FEWI, WAO WHS A GYOUN
WOHEINN  R 20'S 'TWASN ALRELYA
FESA.
DTN' WA NTHEHEINR  TIT CY
WHERTHE PAJASE REWE
BOMBARNGDICH SOOLS ANDTAOS HPI
L
HT  SEENTOHER OMHE T H
EVI
AGLLE.
DWH  ENHENT WE BACK TO
LL WE AG--CKT ENBAISO T  SIVIT
R VIHE T AGLLE,BU T  THENHE
RDNDI'TLIEAT  TZEHAE THENTIRE
PIWAL S NGMOVID.NL IAN
AN
T THD ARTS HIPA UULICARST NI
TS WA--Y HEREWEINLE AVG.
EYINE ERGOEATOG  LN TVEOW
D
AN DHATOTGE O RDWO T
DMANTOHEOTR HIOI JN M IN
THOANY  CERIT THATHEYOU CLD
AVHOATTH W RLEEGION.
AND THEY WERTOE ET ME IN OO-WOHO
CAINI E TH OSOK METHF E
ILCK TADRATOS  NAINNKG D
Y REALADBOENBE EDMB.
SOAIHES  WRD TEFO  YHER,OU
SHOWKN, 'TDIE DNUPHO SW .
HEWA ITEDRFOFO DAYS DAN HE
DN
DIW K'TNOAT THTSTS WAJU
KIG  L AONECMETI BSEAU
TH I MN, THE ILRAHAADROS D
OMENBE BT D BEOUDAN NEEREVYOWA S
R
NGYI TO TGE ON --ON ERY
S TRO NGYI TT T GEOUOF ERTHE.
WHEANTEAID EDWAD ITND A
ENT LYAL I BT GOTO E --IT
T GO TTOHE POINT WHERE HE ALRELY
D AKEACH CEOI.
HEOULDR IT EHEAVLETHE E CITY
DLE EAV HOWOO-ANO DMA EYB
SEVENER WIHIE S  AFEINGA.
ORHE CT LDAIFOR H WISEIF
AND S HIDAUGER A  MTHENTEE
H WUPIT EMTHBU, T SSMITH E BOAT
OUT THOF E ONREGI, OWKNATG INTH
ATTH  WAREALDOUBE  ERRUBY
PA SSES.DIOLER
AND HE WAS SO DEEERSPAT TRIGH
ENEDTUE RNAVO  TLE HE,E
AMSCRE H OEDUTE. NERAM
SC AMREEDITT, OUNEND A O LAST
MP
GRDMS HEWAIN TANREHE SHEN
UCSTHEHEK R  OAD Y AUTNDLED
BA
.CK
WITASE CABEUSAT OFTH FUFATEL
CR
Y HEATTH TRE YWE REITUN.ED
HEOTISRWE, MY ERMOTH DWOUL NERVE
EEVEHA B BON RNDAN EYTHOU WLD
VEEVER ENSE EACH ROTHE
AIAGN.
W>>HEDN DI EYTH AVLEA?CHE IN
>>Y HEDNDI'TLE EAV CHINA TIUNLT
SH
TLORY BETHREFO E
COT UNMMISTIVORELU.ON
SOOUATTH W HENAVBE SOME
METI INTH E .19'S
A
>> REEYTHLI AVE?
FO >>UNELUNRTATTH Y,BO VEHA
SSPAY. AEDWA
GMYTHNDRAFAVE ERLIUPD  TOBE  94
D S AROLHEDAN  SSPAEDAW AYIN
19ND AY  MANDMHER EDDI
ISMMT ASSU.ER
UNRYVE ATRTFOUN SHE E'TDN TGE
STOEE THE BLPUN ATICIOIS OFTH
OKBO.
>> YIDOUTOLKTA OFOT BH TH EM
OUTEE THMAN ALRI IISTH BO?
. Y>>ES
AC
, ALTULYMY GRHEDFANATR BECAE
WASET  APO AAN D NAURLIST
AN D AOKBO THAU,ORHED HA
ITT ABN OUF MESO OINITHS
S TOAUOGRAY.
T  D HAA ANCHCETO INTERVIE
MY ANGRR OTDMHELL ASWEAN DSH E
EDOVPRID OR MEILDETAS BEFOSH REE
EDDI.
>>
HE W  DREIDOWYOGR UP?
>> I UGREWINP ISLIILNO,HI WCH
MHE WREPARES REWE
OFRSSO.
OW HON LDIG U DYOLI ER VETH
>>
MOAL EXALY 2YE0 SAR.
I
THVEMOD  ME ER--ERFAY THAS W
FEOFREPOAD   TISIONEN IWAS
OU
AB1.T
WE
TH TNTO EERUNIVTY TRE DAN
FT
LENK T IHI T AAGE .21
>>RE A EYTH TTI SLLREHE?
Y
>>EY, ESTHRE A.
A HE WREDDI UYO VEMO AFTER
ULE EXAMAI PLN, TRB UANT?HA
OR I>> WKEDFO RTH E CIASSOEDAT
ES
PRD S ANENTHT  W IENE TOTH
HN
JOINHOS PKS ERUNIVTYSI
WRGSIN MISERORSNA PWHAMGR EER
IVREI CE EDMYR'AS MTEI.DES GR
-  -.GRDEEE
ENTH ITIERRD D D.MOVE
W>>HE REDOYOU LIVE NOW?
>>
N I NNSUY ILVE, LIFORNIA
ICWHH  H TISHEF RTEA OETH
NELISICOY.AL VLE
S Y>>OU AYIN ETHBOOK TH E
PAE HSEAVNE RVE APOLOGEDIZ
ISR FOTH.
>>COT'HAS ECT.
NEOFR FICIALLY APOGOLIZED.
>>?HY
>> LL, INK CAE THSERE'
REALLY NO ASONFOR THEM TO DO
UNY TSSHEWE SS PREREO EDUR TDO
.SO
W>>HYHA 'TSN MESODYBO PRRESUD
EMSODOO  ?
UYO E MPCOARITTH WI WH ETH
RM HAS VENEDO.
I>>TH MAKIN YBE GRDEMOCSAPHI
VEHAHIOM SET TODO THWI. IT
SO OF ISTH SMTIACVI BD EHINETH
ENTSS FAEWLYIR N.
BUI D WOULE Y SATHARLDCO WAS H
RGA LAE INILHE T SFCEEN O
ETH PANESEAN D THE CHINESE DAN
E ARICANS ON TH IISSSUE.
AFR ETH UNCOMMTIS REONLUVOTI,
NE
HEITIR KTH IN ETH P.C. OR
TH C.R.O.WA TOEDNT  SUPRESRE
JA
N PATOY PA RAREPAANONTIS  DTO
OLAPBEIZOGE USCABOE  THOF THEM
NE
APEDED JAS  AN ALLYAG NSAIT
THCHEA OER
.TH
DE NEYEEN JAD PAR ECOM
ICAN
TIPOD LIASL CAREANONS D TH
EUN
TAEDIT SSTE AL SOUGSOHT T
JA
N PAASSIT LYALLLS  AWE
AG
THNSAIT ESFOE RCOF  ISMMCOUN
IN
ASIA
>> BACK 1INOW7,93 HA M PNYPLEOE
VEKI NINAN?NG
B>>EFORE ETH BO, INMBGSFOBERE
F MESO OE THACEVS TIUAONAOUABT
MIIOLEPEN OP
>>ATD ANWHWA S ETH TIRELASHONIP
E
CHEETWN A D PAJAN BACK
ENH
WHGOAS W G INON INE THWODRL
D   WATASEIR RETILA?SHONIP
K B>>ACIN 19 ?37
OHS INTHGHA TT HAINPOT
EN NSTEE.
IN THE ERSUMM37F  O19, PAJAH
HHA--ADKETT AACD ANSHAIGH.
METHIS- ADEYTH H --WA R
D
HAY REALADENBROK. OUT
>>UT BS HAWATHONREE AS
?>>
EL WL, ITES GO CKBA A NGLO
WA
T BY,UTAN JHEAPDE ESHA
TUACALLY FND ORHUOFDSRE YE SAR
ONBIAMTIIN CNA.
'S RLLEAY  ITS T'NO
INMESOTHTHAT --WAT  I NOT
SOMEING ATTASTJU SED I
19.
ITAS -- THAE'ERS  LONGSTYOR
OFANY OSIMIT.RE
T' W>>HARETHS E ONAS?
>>
EASO FO--R
T>>HE IMANITOSY?
WL, N,AGAINOOU Y KW, I
KNN'DOT F OW I HWEEAV ENGHOU
MEINGOO  IS TOTH, BUT ETHER
HADYLR AEA YEE BN,OW KOUNWA, R
TWN -- HE TRESWAA  RSFIT
APNOSI J ESANEWA AND THDE ERHA
EN
BEDYLR AEA RONUMEUS TSTEATMP
BY TAP JESE  CPVEAR U
RT
PAOFS CH A.
THAD H REALYAD IZSEED
MA
A HUNCRI THE930'S.
WWAT S IT  DAN WHATISIT
AB
WT OU--S T HAWATH ITE
PARA CSEHAHAERCT T LET DTO
IS
THOFIN KD  TEAUSLGHNGRI?
I ,AN  DWHAT F YIDOUD ININ
THISESPR OCS?
>>EE, 'S COLIMPCATED.
AN
OTHEST RHISAIAORN  IDTHAT
YIERO  TPEIN TO THE JANEPASE
MIND WAS KELI NGTRYITO ARE
WN
DOAC  ABLHOK LE.
IT
RYS  IVE , DVERYLTFIIFCU,
TED  FTOINTOU TIE THMOS
R FOTHIS.
I AYLDOU SUGHOH ATTH IF
YO LREOOT NGKI AETH SOIELDRS
EMESLV ,U'YOD FLLINHA TT
NY
MAF  OEMTHAD HEE BN SO
IZUTBRALED FOBE M TREHEESAASCR
ATTHI  THINK ATTH E TH-- THAT
INNAE NKACMAG SS WREAS AN
ISINE  ICWHH STJU OFCHMU
E
TH PE-UNTP FRTRAT THAT
ADEYTH H PEEXENRID CEDHA
PL
EXOD.ED
S>>O ETHNEJA PA -SE-
>>
APHE T JSOESANE IER S
SYATEMICALLY ZEHAD R YEARS
BEFORE G.NKNAIN
ME,  WHEAS -- YOU HATO VE
AG HJUE STOW OW-- HSENT IEN
TH NEJAPA MILARY PEEXENRICE
REAL W.AS
HEEN TADO RE GEINTTG PESLAP
DAR
BNDY PAJASENE OF.CEFIRS
, MEANWEERTHE RETSCOACUNOF
PAJASOSENE  IELDRSINBEEDFOG RC
WR THH EIEADEUNRWR.
EYTRER WE TEEAD STALMOAS
SU
WUMBHANTHHIITN OWREI N MY
ANFT'SIT ON  BENEETEGGSUESD
DTH
HO TSEOWH VE HAE TH TLEAS
PO
WER CABEN COE METH STMO
SA
STIWHEN T GY HEDONAISO ME
CH
OCEAN TSHNL UEAHE T
ATUSFRTRNIOATTHOTAS W BETL
DIN
.DE
HUC MH SISCDIUS  YHAVE
OUHA
JWID THE ANAPESOPPELE TABOU
IS
TH?VE ENT
>>H, O I --HAD I HA DE TH
UNPOOPRT Y ITTOLKTAGRO  TA POU
OFESAP JANE TSUDSTENREHO W A
STN NGYI IANN SAFRSCCIO, ANDUD
EYSOE ERABTELULY SHTOKEOCD
ND
FIUT OWHAT EDPPHAEN.
I
ANME, EYTHAD  BEEN PTKEIN
E RK OUT  ISTHALL THEIR
LI
VES.
D  SEYAIHEATTH TIR --TH REI
TES BOXTOKCODHA D AINTNELYONE ON
N NELI OETH NAINGMASSREAC
WHTHH ICI SK INWA RRREFE TEDASO
ETH MANHICNG IN.DECINT
I INTHK E ONWOTEN MAAFOWI R SH
EH
TO PEHORSAPGRHE UR BSTINTO
A
TE.RS
S  ISOT'THEACLR  THE-- MA NY
E PAJASENEPE LEOPO T THIS
Y DADON' TALRE LYKNOWAT WH
PP
HAEDEN.
,MEI ANTH E NCNOIGRAEIN  JAPAN
T
ONENS HIEVONANT D HI TS ROTHE
TIROATCI IESLLAPS PAG.IN
,MEAN H I TADAITEDLK WAH
E LLCOEGOFPRSOESR  JINANAP, AND
D  SHEAIATTH WHENHE  NENTMEIOD
S UDSTTSEN-  -MEREERMB,
E ESE ARLLCOE EGUDSTTSEN, ATTH
D N PAHAENBE ARAT WIT WH THE
U.S., MANY OF THESE STUDTS
KE
ASWHHID M DEH ICSION W?
SO
HEN  IOTS,WOR RD EYTHE'RNO T
BEHTTAG UGOU AB ITHT ISTN HEIN
AHOSCOL THEINOFTRISY
DE
S CADENSCEORHIED TS EVENT AND
RORSHE FTHEI BOTEXTS.OK
METH, IS H BASEN EETH
T BJSUECOF -YLAEAR UWSIT
TWE NTH JAPAOVSENE GNTNERME
AND  HMOFAUSANTOISRIE.THS ER
>>
IS TH EER A INCHE ESLOHOCAUST
MUSE?
>>'SHE TRE APE RA OF NKNAG
SE
MUUM IN NKNAG.IN
ITSHA AG BINU ERMB 0,30000
SCOND  I T BT,UTT'HAS
ABOUITT .
T PELE IN ANLOS WHLEGES
OAR
E INREST ININUI BLDAG
E INCHESUSLOHOCAT UMMUSEN I IS
CO
.TUNRY
>> SOUAYTHATTH US EHOE OF
PIVNTSEAT I GESOTISO NTTH?
L W>>EL, LYTUACAL TH'SAT
INMESOTHDIG T ERFFENATTH'STH E
LI
NPIBISKI .LL
I D'TTHEA MN Y  TATHETGO
HETOIN T LOHOUSCAT SEMU ,UMTBU
E THE WHOLSUISHEOFE  T PERA- -
L, W>>ELS HA TT'GHRIT.
LL MNSLIPI,KI A DECRMOAT
FR
IN IOMLL HSOI,RO IASNTCEDUD A
LLNGN  ICOSSRE ATTH CASLL R
EJA TNEPASEO FIOFCIAL
IZOLAPOGTOE  ITS WORLD WAR II
S CTVIIMD ANY PAREPAS.TIRAON
AN
DTH PERAOF  G NKNAIN OISYNL
NESP A TT ECOF BHEILL.
HESST THNYMA O AERTRITOCSIE
SCHSU A THE KORE MFCOT ORMEWON
ISE,HE T DIL
PEXERTIENIMTAT  TONHAETH
PAJAHASENE UCCOD NDDTE INGUDCLIN
VIE IOSEVICTOUWIN THT
ESESANTHAM OIAN  AICERANND
E INCHESERISPRONOFS  R.WA
ETHANBATAAT DEHMA H.RC
ARERTHE MA SEO ER ONYTH
INCEANS  T WOFAREIM ROATESCITI
REATTH AONEN MTI IN S LLBI,
D IT'STH-  -I K INTY HEVEHA
RE
MOHAN 30 SURSORPPTETRI GH
NO
COINW  .RENGSS
W WAT SETH INKILLG T?NTCOES
YO
U IOMENTD NEIT E,LIARERWHO
T ESDO IRKWO?
>> OH,TH E INKILLG T.NTCOES
WE
TLL,ERREHE WTWE O
SUUTIE WANENTSHO  TNTWAEDSEO
EWH
COO D ULLLKI 100 EINCHES
RS
FI
AN
D ETH PANESEME ADI DVECORE
TH
AV ISLYIDAS   IIFT WASMESO
NDORF SPVENGTI E.NT
DAN EY--  WHENEY TH HEREACD
YTHE, KOUW,NO THMA10E 0 , RKI
ES THS EY DHALOST TSCOUN
OK T'LESST JUUP  ISTH . 1TO50
>>
HAOU Y VE TGO THE ALACTU
WRTERAP ALEIC?
>>RIT'HAS T.GH T
C Y>>OUE ANSEETH MBER 510
10DAN 6.
WHATS  ITH?
>>THAT'S WHO OSCL WTHE EYE.ER
EY
THER WE RUNEINNNG   CKTONE.
ONE DHAKI EDLL5 10 OPPELE,
AN
HEOTR HALOD FFEDBB O 10 6HE.AD
T
>>ST HAWAAC ALLY PUISBLHED
PAJASE NEWSPAPER?
>>HAT'T.COEC
ISME ASSOTHINTHG E TH
JAEOSENE PEPL KN OUABT AT
TITHE .
W>> HOWA STINDCOUCE NGTH
CO
?ENTST
>>ES H,THO ETW--
IHON,EA WS WA CHALGNGLEIN
TH
AEMND WHOSE IDEA ITWAS O T DO
?
IT
ICLOT N ONEAR TH E DEILTAS
OF IS ,BUTH ISWAS NOT
L.PITYCA
THIS WAS WAATWH  INHAENG
TH
UGRONK HNAG.IN
IN NKNAG,IN THE JA TNEPASENUR
RDSPNT IO T.OR
NOTH ESM N ESIL OETH JANEPASE
ININTHEGR NDOU, DAN  REHE'SETH
PH
GHO OTRI.HET RE
WH
YE ERDOND OUFITH OSPHOT?
>>REY ANWE LATE COLLECTED BY
THNAE INNKG GOVERNMENT FOR THEI
A
ESCRR IM TRS UNIBALAIAGET NSTH
JA
ANEPASEHEERFT TAR W.
TISOT MEES METH SEPAJANE
SOTHRSIE ESSEEMLV OKTOHE TSE
PIURCT.ES
WHKE T IAL WID TH E ONOFETH
SU
SIVRVOREMHE,  R ABEEMRSHES
OOSTD,OU Y,KN OW ONETH  OFGEED
S
TH IT PNGTCWAHI LL AETH
JAOPSENE L OFF ADHES ANDRO THW
TH
TH TEMO DE ESIAN D Y, OW,
ONN ERPSOEPS WAKEUNG INCOT,
KEE SPINGRECO AHEND T OTH OER
NEA
S LA AHIUGNG TNDAKING
OTPHRAS.
YO,KN OW ERTHS E'AN IBCRINEDLE
ABORSTY  TOUHOWTH  EONAL MBU
OF16  OTPHS RAOGPHENEVALTULY
TSMA I OMY WAFR SHO PTOP HOTO
LI
E --TOO  TA YOETIL, ,KNU OW
S  ITWA FDDHIEN ORARYES L UNTIIT
DEEND TP  UIN ARCVE
S.>>
A CO FLEUP OE TH URPICT IESN
RE
HEOURE A RLO TGHO  AOKT.
AS WAITTOUG DE TSICION OTPU
THEMN TK? BHEOO
I
>>WAT S.
IT
AS W.
S RYVE NCCOERDNE  THATMESO
TTU PSEICS REWOULD SURELT
TBEOO BK G BAEDOM FR
SC
OLHORIIB LRA.ES
TBUI D HA NUROMEUS USDISCONSIS
T
OFS HITHWI ETH OPPELE AT
HAINCOERLL ANS DTHWI HEOTR
HISTIA ANDNDFRIE
ANME SO OPPELEINSTSIT  TEDHA
THTPU EMIN  YWANAY UNEDNSCEOR
E CABEUSASISTH WORHI STS TY,HI
S H.TRE UT
>>S HA WT'HOISTH P OVEHERE?
>> TT'STOHEHO OF A WOMA
WHO -- A RAPE VICTIM WHO IS
BEING FORC TO POSE NEXT TO A
PAOL SDIER NAKED.
TH FOUND THESE PHOTOSEN  ITH
LLOMOFS  SOF E PAJASENE
SOS.IELDR
K  TEYOOHETM.
MES TIMEETH OPPE ILENE TH
CA MHO PTO WATLDOUMA KE
PI,USCAEEY TH EW HO
IMPOTHANRTT E. WEYER
>> THN EPAHEOTR T GEATP HETO
TATWH'STHA OTPHO?
S ILLTI VEHARO PEMBLSOO LNGKI
ATT. I
AATTH'SNWO MAHAWH O EN SBE
D PAIMLE TEAFRS E SHHAENBE
PERAD.
D>>OWN HERE?
ANWHERE DIFIYOD U  TH?
IS >>TH N AGAIROMECA FA.CHM IN
WA -- IT ME FROMTH
CH
ESINEAR.IVCHES
T A>>NDTO PHEHO IBO AVET?
A'S PIOFURCTE   AWOMA
WHO'BE NG PERAD DAN E SH--
YUL OUCOED SE, E SHS BE
TI TO AIE THCHSO AT S
COULBED  RAPED ENWHEREVE TH
LDE  WRSERHEIN TFOOO MD
RIT
.AN
D AIAG  IN,MEAN, I VEHA AHA
TI
OK MELOGIN  ATESTHE CTPIESUR.
EN NOW.
>>THT'HAS OSPUE RPUTOFE PNGTI
N EMTH IOKE THBOHE TN?
U INDECID ,TE NDHA WTS WA--
TH
E CONVONSAERTIBEIK LE EETWN
U
YOED ANTH PUR?ISBLHE
>>
EL WL, ERTHE  REWEPEOP ILEN
E PUNGISBLHI OU HSE OWHDHA
PIURES.I LMSOOTH ANGT CT
IN HED,EN WDEE CIDED TATTH I
POS WAIMFOANRTT LEPER OPSETO
WH
THEWERE PACABLE OF DNOIG.
S
THTEAFR TOUGDECIONSI.
- A WITASHTO UG ONCIDESI.
I
OW I YMA LLWETCH AT LOOF
CRISIC FM B IORT,ON IUT DIT
'TTH
ATK INTHEO PEPL LLWI IZREALE
JUSTHOW UTBRAL THE PAJASENE
RETHTIUNL  EYE SEESTHE
CT.ES
I I>>F WE REA NEJAPA SETTIN
G
NDREHE AHEAW S TWO, SEI YD ULSA
N
THE LGSIK WH'SAT URYO OOPRF
AT
THHE TSE WERE  BUSCAEDY A
PA
JASOSENE IELDR?
>> LL A INCA YSAIS HE TREARE
THSOUANF DS OOFGEPAS MA PRIRY
URMEDO CU S NTONISTH TEVEN
AN
INFO UR ERDIFFTEN LASUANGGE
THY RE PTTCHMUIBES DCRWIE TH
RD ESTHERYVE PI.URCTES
AN
MAD NY OFTHEES CTPIESUR,
THNOE'R --T  EYTHDIDN'T LAL
ME OM PAJAN ANDCH A.IN
MAAN C BE UNFOIND  TTE UHENID
NATSTESISHE T MYONSIAR --IN
E
TH SSMINAIORY ECLLTIS.ON
LME OW SHU YO ISTHPI URCTE
HEGHRIT   ARENDMELLTE  TATWH I
IS
THE ONERIO E GHT?
>>
IGHE T RTO UHTP
O
>>
>>HE BAYONET.
>>TH E TTYOBANEG.
LLE ESARE URCTES O THE
SEPAJANEAYONTINGVICTS,
DTHDO'REYE G IT FO
PRCETI.
THEY'R USGVELI PRISONERS AS
PRCEACTI
D  C YASOUEELDOU S,E TH
INE WHO' BEND BENLI,LDFOED
MES E  HHA BEENABBE
RE
LYATPEED.
ISD ANTH IS HAGENPPINEV  ENTEAFR
HE D'SEAD.
>>U YOEYTH IS JUST TIPRAC?
>>
PUS JTE.CTRAIC
TEL BOWIST HATHGRHO PTOH?AP
T IS PHOTOGRAPHOF
SE
RALCHINESE VTIMSBEGIN
ALEDRI EIV ASAP JANESEU
SOLDIERS WCH.
>> AND YOU AL SOLLTE STORY IN
THERERWHE THEY WLDOUUR BY SOME
INEES IMVICTO UPS  TTHEIR
ADD TH HAVE ANGERM
EPS RD--
T ATHR EMRTPA.
>>
THEA TR  EMARAP
U O  DYONYVEHA AURPI CT OESF
ATTH?
N
>>O.
TH
D.K ANGO
>>HO WID DOU YIN F OTHD AT?UT
L, W>>ELHA TT --WAS TH ATCA
TOU - OF -OWU YOKNIVAR, CHAL
CU
DOSONTME, CAT I OU METOF
PTSCDERIHINSIO W  CHIUND IN
INCH
I'LLTEUG INYO, TELIILLRAY D HA
NY SOMACT FAS ON ESTHE
ATTICIES, I --HAD  I HADTO
US
AE  UTCOMPAB DERATASR E FOEM
INO ERRD THEEPKE T Y,KN OUOW,O
IN
ER ORD.
I MEAN, WE DHA ATTHMU CH
ID
EVN CEEN O.IT
>>WEF HAWH--D DI END UYO
ARSTT GITWRINISTH BOOK ORWH EN
UD DIYOTST AR COILL G INALETH
ATINRMION?
>>TART CNGPIOMLIHE T
ATFOINRMOBN IOPRNLYAB I JANUYAR
RYBRFEUA 9519.
>>OT IND NHAEDIC TT LASE ATAS
-GUAUSTSTAL- MONDHE T EF O
AU
OUSTGU YHA D INMESOTHQUG EDOT
H
INOME ERFRETH  NJAPA METIS,
AN
D THISBO OK MECA TOUIN
ERCEDEMB.
WHO --DID HO W RE YOABU  LETO
BLITH  TOST HACLE?
>>
,EL WLYO USE  E, WE HADTO
ISPUBL THH ISATGHRIT  TH ESTLA
ECTENU BLLSEAU ATHF O IS
AC
SMVI, 'SITNGNG OOIND A WE
REWE ALRELY RKWOWNG INDO TO THE
A
NU STMIN O  BTHISK.OO
WAS A VTIERY SCGHT .DUHELE
HY A W IS-- UYO,EA MNOU Y
WE
RA REAF W YIDOUINE ERGO TO
HESELO TRTOP POIFITUNY YO U
GDNDI'T IETT PUD ISBLHEGHRIT
AYAW?
'SA NGLO STOR
RPHACOERITINLLS S LFSE AOWU YOKN
HAENBEGHHR TOU ICDIFF ATYND
EYTH VUANLCRNE EDIS- - EDNCCAEL
E
MOTH AN 0 10ONOKBO C.ACTRTS
U ER, OWTH SWEE REE YSDELA
TINHES.OCPRES
T TH WATAS OK USBECAATE TH
GA
VE  MERTOPPOTOITUNY  PUT IN
OT
FOR HEINN ATRMIOHOATTH SDUL
ONVEHA G  EINTHE OKBO.
RNEI VE TOUTHGH RFOINSTCEAN
THAT  ULWODDEN UP INFINDEG TH
MIFALY OF HNJO BAROY,E TH NAZI
HE
NA OROF INNKG.
YO
OWKN, I TELOCADITHD E IES
AN
TELOD CATHD E MIFALYLFY
H ROTHUGE PJE.
SO
AN  IME THI WAS  GGOONIN
PR
S.ES
Y TA LK HI UGDAER?
OR ANDDGHR TE--
>>
S HA TT'GHRIT.
ME,I'VE D ACTRKETHWNDO E
FA
LYMI WHENNK T IHI TH EOKBO WAS
MO
AL FINHED.
SOYE ,S VIRESIONS  REWEDEP U
E TOTHST LA NUMI.TE
>>
HO W IS HNRO BAY?
WAOH JN  TH  OHEAD FETH TD
SIRTYIN NANKIN H BG,UTWAS
SO T HEAD  ETH
INTEATIOFEL NASATYNE
COITTEE INNAICINWHH IS
THE GROUPAB TOU 20FORSIGRENE
O  DECID TOEACRTE IN NKNAGIN
A 2 1/ MUASQREEIL AREAR FO TH
E
ESFUREGEG UR DINSSE THMAREAC.
EYLDTO ETH SEPAJANETH ATTH IS
EA ISARWA  SOFF  MILITSTO
EM, ANDTH  EYHAD  TOFEED THE
ESFUREGEND A T OTPRECEMTH OMFR
ETH SEPAJANE.
YAAV HE ERLE TT TEDAD 8
NEJU, 1938.
ILLCAR  DEDEAROFUR, -- ARDE
HR,ER GNSIEDHN JO ROBA
R
>>GHIT.
THTOEN WT LEITR.
W
>>?
>>
E WANGTRYI TOST E TH
HIGHTES CIATROESTI.
H MHEAYENE AVBETT  ALI LEIVNA
E
U
EAHET  ROUY LLTHATT GHTH
RHPEAPS THE GEANS ULD
PRRSUE E THSEPAJANEO  TOPST
LLE THKIG.IN
WSO DT HAHE WIDAS 38 19 WHEN
T  WHEENCKTO  INBERLHE,
T OUBRGHIMTHWI H C AOPY OFJO HN
GEM  FSIL M TOFHEESAASCRDAN
HN MEE WAS THE --WA S THE
IS MLIPAANRISINTEWHTOO OK
OTOFE  OFMESO  ETH
ROESTI.
LYTUACAL HE, 'SETH NTGEMALEN
RI
TT GHON OHETHE. PERAG
CH W>>HI E?ON
>>TU PHEICRE 'STHAT ALI LETT
LOHEONR  TGE PA.
>>
HWH ICON--E
T HE TGHRIT.
ISMANTGELE
N.>>
K. O
NEFI.
WE
T L 'LGEHE IT RESOPE LEOP NCA
SE
HWHE AT EOKSLI.
OT SH ESSCEN FM ROTH
EN
HKIANNGTAOSPI
L.
D IT WAS THIS FILMHA S
PRODED AND, YOU OWKN N
ANSHGHAI.
IT
S WAUGSMGLED OUTF  ONKNAGIN
AN
MA DE VESELRACO ESPI.
HNOB RAYONOO TK HEOFE  T
CO H AESNDPT EKEDI S RIOFI
E .ACSSRE
HEGHBR OUT E THOSONAL HWIG TH
IMO
N.ER BLI
ANT SHEEN A  COPYOF ETH LMFI
LE HTOITR.
AN
ASHED  W HOPING TOMA KE MESO
NDKIF  OIGU SES ANCHGE INNER GMA
I
POAR TCYOW JAP, BUTHT E
T F LTSU OE -- OF INSENDG
THE LMFI WAS AITIS FEM ROTH
ST
GEO.AP
DANEY THCA  HIS MEHO,
EDREARST IIM H,GAERNTROM.D TEHI
FOR  AURHOS,NDALENEVTULY EYTH
FO HRCEDIM  PTO TMIROSEHETHM
NOU WLDEREV KSPEAOUTTH E
ROS ITIEAIAGN.
WTH IRES M? FATIL
THAS A ODGO ESQUONTI.
WE, LL MJOHN FEECG'SM ILIS
AI TE BLIN UNID STESAT.
IME , ANLVESERA ESCOPI REWEMADE
IN'REYE  DITERFFEN ARIVCHES
ANIN DIERENHOT S,ME TBU JOHND
GE SOY, JOHN Y'ROBAS
WEPYCO, DO N'T OWKNWH E ERIT IS
E
USCAE  HOPPELESEEAV  CHAREDETH
RM
GEAN CHARESIV DAN ANEYTH C'T
FI
INDT.
T TDAS Y, NY'HEREE  SOTURIF
TLSEAS H , ENITBU T THE
FA ILYS INCONVDCE ATTH HE D.DI
>>U F IYOWSAE THJO HN GEMCE
WHLMFI, LD WATOU YO UY?SA
YOULWOD ESEETH  CIATROESTI?
YD WOU ULOPE SEPENG BLEEI
AYD LEAWTHY B E NEJAPASE
LD
SORSIE.
VEU YOHAMEO  TREEERMB HDNCO UL
'J
ICT USSTCATHK E PRAME UOU, Y
KN
RI, GHT IN FRTONOF  EITHR
CEHAHI TS BETOD  DO
CREY.TL
C YSOOUEELDOU SFOOM SE AGOTE
AT ILIS FROD METHUGHLIKE
A YBMAE ACCRK IN ETH DOOR OR A
ACHEK  T WINW.DO
U D ANYOSEULWOD E CROW OF
E INCHESTAINBEG AWNKE .
STTHMOGRIPPING AGIME CESOM
OMPI HHEOSERL TAWHE THEER
VRE WTIICMS HHOAD--  OWH HA
D ESPEBEING RNBUEDIVALE.
OPADHO W HEE BN SLWIHEASD TH
YO
BATSNE.
TH
ONE'ERS  PIURE ERWHE EON
WON'MA IHES AD AJUS STOUTBO T
LL.FF
IITSALREY  VLYERQUOTGRESE.
>> SHA ISHO W?
>> AT HAISESAP JANE RAVETEOFN
TH
RAPEF NAINNKG.
AN
TIHED  SLL --HE 'S STILLAL EIV
AND  IHE'SPAN JAN GHRINOT W.
AOU Y CORREDPOESNDI WTH
M?HI
T' T>>HAECCOS RRT.
>> DOWIDATTH WORK?H
HOW DI DYOUFI  NDM?HI
>> WELLI , D HATO TCKRAOWIM H D
D ITH KIN A NAURLIST RUBAMA
S
WATHEONE WH MGAO VEHIE S
ADDRS.
I
A OTWRE  TTLEERTOHI M, IHA D
TREDSLANATNT IO JAPESANE.
D NDES RPO MOAL
STIM
ELDIMEATI ANY D DHA THELE ERTT
EDSLANATAC BIN ENISGLH.
HE SENT ME A COPY OF HIDIS IEARS
N
D ALSO EDSWANEREV  YERQUTION
HA
I  D POSE. HTOIM
SE
AS IE, WG RY TINER UTONDANSTD
ETHSTATE D  MOFINTT HA I WHEAS
NT
IMHE T TE.
HA WT DDI YOUEA LM  FRNROM?
T W>>HANELEI AR T WDASET HATH
PA
JAOLSENE SERDI RELYALAD HO T
SE THE EESCHIN  SUUMBHAN
FOHE TY DCOUL LL THEM.
I  ,HE DE CTPIEDTHESCHE INE
D HINISSRYIA A, YOU OWKN, AS
KE ALANIMS ORS  ASECT
>>GHRIABT ATE OVTHE N ITHOK
YO
CAU THPUN T O IISNTHE T
NTEXT, A TEVERAN OFFICER NAMED
GAMITONO EDCARELL VIVIDLY HIS
OW
NTRANSFORMAON FROM NONT
TOUTYOH NGIL KLINEAC MHI
.I
ONTWA T ADRE OUATWH YVE HA IN
RE
HE.
WHD E ERDIFIUYO AT NDTH ,BYE TH
A
THAT WAS IN THE SEARCONDY
SOURS CETHATAM CE FR OM AOKBO.
>>HE SCOOPE DWATER FROM A
BUETCK WITH A DIERPP, ENTH
PO O EDITTHR VEBOID S OESF ETH
.ADBLES
SS D ZEHI ORSWD,NGANSTDI
BENDHIHE T ISPRERON,HE  STE DDI
HIMSELF LEGS SPRERT AADPAN AD
F T CUOFETH MAS N'HEH  WADIT
OUT.
ETHBL D OOTESPURD UPNT IO OTW
FOUNTAINS ANYESPD RA IND TOETH
LE
HO.
THE SCENE WAS SO APLLPAG INI
FELT I COUL'T BATHE.
YOU WERE NEJAPAAT, SEWHOU WLD
NTU YOWA YO URN LEPEOPO TDO
ABISOUTH?
IF THEY DN'IDOWKN AUTBO IT.
WELL, I S GUESWO ULD PEDEND
ONIV IHEND BUAIDL,UTI  TDON' T
OWWHY  TATHEULD INK, BUT
K THI IN I-- ONPERSHILYAL T
ATHE T AHAY VE 1OR MAL7B309--
M
A  RORALNSESPOY ILIBIT COM
PS GTORI WI THIS.
JAN ASIO N AATNCA NNOTMO
FOTID ARUNEY LTHME ETTH IS
SQUAL TY INE. FHEAC
>>L,EL EVENINCOACRDTOG URYO
ONSTTEIMY  TY,HEKNN'DOT OW
OUT.
OM I>> STHOFE DON'T KNOW
OU
ABT , BUTHERE E OSE
WH
.O DO
AND I ERMEREMBNGAL TKIMEO  TSO
JANESEWHWH O Y  TENHET,ARHE I
EY
THNYL 'LDEIT .
THEYNTN'WA TBEO EVLIE IT.
IT  'SVERY ,RDHA RYVERD HA TO
OWY ACEXTLWHOTHEYGOE 'RGIN
TO EACRET,N WH THE FACTS
ARE STTHRU TOINTH REICE FA
>>
WILLOUR OKBOBLE  BPUHEISD
INPAJAN?
>> N'MOT ALRELY TIOPMIICST
ATLLT WIE, B SRHPEAP
INMESO KMAOFD  SLL, RICADAL
PUBLHEISR WILL TAKE A RISK AND
PU
UTITT  O.
FM ATWHU  YOOWKN,T WHA
ULPPEN IFTH OKBO DTRIE
TOSOE B OV LD ERIN PAJAN?
>>
'T D ION,KN OWT BU I' LLLLTE
ATU YOTHTH EE ON 'STHATME COUT O
TO IZOLAPOGE R FOLES HIROEN  ITH
SS'S, REHE AC FEDESUNCOTL
ATS RETHATDAN  MANYOFTH E
JOS LINASTOWHVE HA WRTEITNR
OUISTH IN HAP JANTHE AVEI
ERBE
ENTROS -IZACEDANI - ME,EN WH
YOU SE ETHEM RAOTPHOGTHEDPH, EY
A
VE NGSU OSSLAESBEN USE, YOU
OW
KN, TH'VEYE -- THEY'VERUN
IN
ES TOTHS KIE NDF OTHREAT'S
E.TH
N' TRGFOETHE -- MESO
JA
NESERING WISHERNGS  IOT
THTHK E YOMAROF  NI ASAGAK
E THIMCKBA SY PLCABEE HESA
THOUE  HTHTGH HITOROHIAD HAT
MESO REONSPTYBISILIHEOR F TWA R.
T T>>HAS WAIN9 1.89
TS GHRIT.
W AHAVEOU CHARYNT TIST
IVILINGDENI.
D HL 'LBE WESONTH YO I
AM
MPCOTELELY LLAPPAAT EDTHMO RE
OP
PE'T DLEONNO KW ABIST OUTH
ATBETYCI, USCAEIF U YO  -LOOK-
I ME, 00300,0 OPPELE EDDIN I
NK AG,ND 0,30000 PELEOP
GH EMT NOSEA IK LE GEHU
MBERUNTIU LYO ITACPLE N I ETH
CO T EXOF RLWODRWAII  HIORSTY.T
30000,0 DEHSAT AT GISREN TERHA
EATDEHS OMFR HIA SHROIMDAN
GA KIMBCOEDIN.
'SIT ALSO TEGREATHR ANTH E
MB
CO EDVILI HSDEAT OF
SEROL RAEUPEAN IEUNCOTRFOS R
E ENRETI RADUOFONTI WO  DRLWAR
.
II
SO IOTWOHER F S,RD ID U YOADUP
TH MBNU OERCIF S LIVIANO DI
D,GLENANRA FE NCAND LGM,
ATTH'S --STHA TT  LILWOULD NOT
ABESNY PE LEOPWHO EDIN
NKH WHG ICE ISON ESCHINE
TY INSI X HT ETOIG.EE WKS
IN
NDHE T E,MO RE THMI 1AN9 IOLLN
CHOPE ESPELE PE.SHRIED
19LION LEPEOP REWE KILLED.
>>ATWH DO YOWAU NTO DOITH
IS?
EL WL, NTI WAE TH OLWHE RLWOD
TO
WNO KWPPT HAHAEDEN.
I WANTNTHE T ERLE IRWOD TO OWKN
H
UTTRH.
>> ANDOW HREAR F AILOU Y WNGLI
E  TTOAK?IT
TH, LLI VEK INI' --US JT
RI B TNGHEK ISHE -- S
THGGE BIEPT ESSTEA RR Y LLFO.ME
K THI IN DHAI VE PE ONMYTIN
LASTJU NG WN E THFOCTFAS
RPE
O LEOP TADRE.
>>ND SOALN THBOK,OOU Y
OMVEHA SE AMERANS.
ONIN RTPA IULICARS BERORT
WI
N.O
O HES
?>>
OBERWIONLS ISS -  -WAA
MIRYIOSSNAR OC DTODAN HEWASE TH
ONLY S IGEURONNKNAINNGDUG RI
E
TH MAEAGRT ACSS.RE
A WH ATROLE DID HPLE ?AY
>>EL WL, T WHEASSO PHEERWHN OEN
DED UP HAVING TO STIUPTCH HE T
RVO S ORWHMECAOU, YKN OW,
ST
GGRALI INGE O NTTHALSPHOIT
FRETAY BON DSWOUN WBU, RNNDOUS
D ASHE WORIGKI NHT A DND
Y.
DA
'SINLEEDCRIBAT WHE H  SWAABLE
D
TO ODEUNR OSTHE IONDCOIT.NS
HA
WE WATHNE
>>HE T RNINTELIOATNA TYSAFE ZONE
S ITWA 22 1/SQ REUA MIINLES HE T
ODDMILECITHF E TY, WHECHHI T
REFONEIGRS HADARKED OFF TH
DRE ANAGFLS   WITAS  ARE
ATCLYHE THMEAID TH ATE
PAE WSEERNO T TERMPEITTOD
R.
TE
TH
EYSTJUREAR HBOCHTHD E ESINE
ERTH
OUOFSND  INES REWE
POTOG ININ TH ENEZO YEVER DAY.
ITNYMA WLY HON THE S OTCLHEON
EIR CKD SANJU ST G GGBEINRFO
A
ACE  TDOSO TH AT TH
EYCO
D ULBE SAFE  -FROMFR- OM THE
SEPAJANE
.>>
ANOW H MLEPEY OP  IWEREIDNSE
ATE?ON
>> NDHUF DSRE OOUTHNDSAS.
ON
ALACE TUSA LYID 0,000.
ON TOFHEZO NE MBMESERSA
WE000,0 TH IREN NE EZO.
Y ATE LLYST OR OUABTHO W
EINCHES LDSOWORSIE MED ULCO IN
AN
THD ENETH PAJASENE  ULWODMECO
.IN
D W HODIEY FIND ,THEM ENWH
TH
OK EYTOOF FTH R IFUNMSOR AND
PUON CILIVIAN HECLOTS.
W THD  EYNDFI EMTH?
WEL THEY CHSEAREI EDTHR
TONDHAS F EE S IADEYTH HNY A
LLUS FROM LIHANDS. GNGUN
THLS AOEV EN EDARSECH EIEY
BAEETOS  SHEIF  TER WEAN Y
PACKBA  CKRKMAS.
EV FHE TIRFOTEE R SSIGNOF
HIMARC.NG
THTHWA Y E  WEYERO LEAB TNDFI
OUO WHHAD ENBE RMFOER ESCHINET
RSLDSOIEAND THEY
ATSTSYEMALLYMATHHERCD  TOU
D
ANTHOTSH .EM
WE THS ERL TRA IA  AOFNYNDKI
OF --A AF  RTETHER WA WAS ER?
Y
>>
S.WE
, THBIONESGGT THWAE S
ETO
R O KYWA TIMCRESORALRI TH E
FORME  NALAM I TISHETIERNTNAALON
RYLIMITANARI TBUL FOR THE FAR
EAST.
AND THATD ASELIN JAN, AND
IT RESULT IEDNFSO OTH ECLASS
A R WAIMCRALINS HAINBEG EDNG BY
THE END OF THE--
WAS E THEREVNGYTERHIHA TT
HA
IENPPEDDWON RLWA RII
AENPPED TTHT ISALRI?
,MEI AND DI IT R COVEYTEVERNGHI?
>>E Y IS,--WAT S WEHE TY RE
YIVEO  TCOYTEVR ERNHI
G.BU
THO EYLSHAD A LOIAL CATR
LTO
FOO R INNANKG.
E ERWAS A NATRINNKG UNIB AALS
LLE
>> ANDOW LD G ONDIO ATTH G?ON
I
>>NT TWEON R FOSE RAVEL
MONTHS.
IT WAS MAINTH -LY- EES REWELD HE
ATMEIMDITEY ELAFWATHR E
R.>>
WAHA TT HELD IN INNANKG?
Y
>>.ES
UR OFCO,SEE TH TEINNAATRNIOL
TR
UNIB  FALORETH RFA STEA STLAED
NS
COLYERIDABERLO NG.
MENT ,WEON  FORYE S.
>>CH OWMUCIUB PLI WTYAS ERE
ISR FOTH EVTEN,IT EHER IN
NK GOR IN PAJAN?
>>HEL,EL T C WREASSIONDERAEBL
PU
Y.ICBLIT
I  WK INITE ASTH ESNGT RWA
IM IRI TAL NHIORSTYHEND A T
YHA
REHUD NDRE ODSF S RTPOERERTHE.
IN INNANKIT W LLWE
IZBLPUICM EDI'SU RE THHOUGUT
INCH
>>L TOUELOR ASTINY ETH
INGIBENNTHOFG  BOE OK ABOUT
ORMMCOODHEMAE TTRR WPED  YANHOW
E
TH AMS ICERANENOPED UPAPANO
THUTEOID SD.WOE RL
W HOIDD THAT RK?
>>H,LLWE,WH RRPEY DCIDEDE
WH DTOO  J TENHEEANAPES DNOIGRE
TSQUREESM  FROE THANERAMIC
VE
GO MERNNTTOOP EN UP RTHEI
PO
S RTOF ADTRE,  MHE CHARED -UP-
HE
UDSTD JA HNEPASETORY
CA
Y.FURELL
ANENTH  DHE TIDECEDTHT HA
E
AYSTBE WO DEAL THWI THEM SWA
TOTHCKHO O  IEMNTSIBMSUIS.ON S
SO HE -- HE F NDKI OAMSTJU CE--
JU WT ENRIGHITUPT  WH Y,OU
KN, OWTOOFNE O TH E S RTAND HE
ST
NTDERO ICATHO E WITAPIL TH
MERYVE AGESSIKI LVEOO MNGEN
D IT STJU IERRTEIFTHE
PATH ASET .TIE ME
MEANETHFI TIT RSME EYTH DHA
ER
EVVE EN SEAM SENTEOW PER.
ON IASTHIORSA N IIDT ULWOD
BE
-- OWU YOKNEATO,  RYLL
TADEUNRSNDE TH SUPRESRE THE
E ANAPESNDREWE U W, ERITELDOU B
KELIAN  UNANNOMENTMAYBE ON
N AT  HWEEAV SOME DWEIR
LOINAIG RARCFT HEADEDDSOW TAR
RTEAH.
AT HASOW D OCSHKEEREYTH WE
T
ATME HETI.
AND TH IS ISIN JULY OF18 .53
Y.>
>>T TASHAFIETH TRSMETI PAJAN
D EVER SEEN AN ICAMER?AN
P TBBALY FIR TNYE IMMA
HAEVER S N EEANERAMANIC.
PP ATHAEDENO TTH E UNCOYTR
TEATTH
?>>
EL WL, THENDY CIEDO T
IZDEMORNANE D THID DEYEC THA
EYLDOU PEAPEE ASTH
BA
NSARRBIAHEUT B TDWOY ULY TRTO
AROMFR THEM, CABEE USIT SWA
OUSBVIOHA T WTHT EYGGE ERLAGIN
HN TINECLOO.GY
EYLE TADO N  BTOPLDUI U
EIR MILITARY.
>>
HA WT PPHAEXEDEN N TTOTHE
COTRUNY?
>>ELLCOTH, E DITRUNY
DPR
Y ISECELAT A THE WREAS THE
J
MA -- THS E ERWAJOE THMA
RRE
ATSTORN IOAND THE ENRETI
CO
Y UNTR CABEMENAONTIC ISALTIDAN
D, TINENHE TY UPILBUT Y V AER
RO
STNG RYLIMITAD AN EYTHEG BAN
TO G SETOMOFHE T SPREECAT
THRAAD H CTUD VEACROLYAL FY
M
E STWE.
>>
ES DO E THRAPEOF  NAORINNKG
TH
MAE  ACSSREAT1
VEMP NYINT ACOT HE
RELATNSIOHITOTWDABEEEN
AND AAJPN?
TAYOD U  TLKOO FS LKABHAT OUT
YENOUWE NT EROV  ERTHE?
VET' IS  INRESTG INATTH
K U YOAST, TMEHACB EUSAEAM YNFO
ETH. PCR. .OFFALCIITS HA TI'V  E
E
ATHT ATREV EYR SYAPMICTHETT O
HH
E ORSITF YOT EH PRAET A
NAANG,IN MYMY AA HVE HAD  K
RE WIVATESD DHOIED IURNG THE
R
WAUT T TS HEMEA ITEM I THINK
THRRE A CTLEUANTOT  DENANG ER
TH
ADR EITRLRE ENSTAIO WTIH PJAAN
NDOLAS TEHOP TILICALA ND
DI
PL RATOMICIOELATO NS SHTE
PS . .CHACA AALTULY SIAM  YR
HANM ETI EDONBEOFR PXELE  DLE
ACS VITISTVEO WHHARIEDTO
PRISE OTTH EEVNT ACUALLY,
OMHTHE E  OTOISRYH FTA ERPE TPR
INNKG.
IN EAB CK  OFURYOBOK YOU
Y THE  AREREU ANBEM ORF
SS
LES.ONAN
LEHEOTR OONSS TB EEG LFNA RED
NKNAING THE ROLEP OF WOER IN
NO
OSHAWHE O VE TSUEDDI THE
VEOTDET HO CNCRAENTON O F
WE INEROVGISENNMT  LELHTA AN
OND LYE ASENS OFA OSBLUTE
CHECKED WEPOR CAMAK
OCTRITIELI TKEHE REAP OF
NAINNKG POIBSS.LE
WATLDAY Y S THENA OBU T
DANECHS IO SECCENATIOON F
INWEPOR  TH ATGOVENERNMT?
THE PR.CDA TO ISSILL A
YONKO W,IF YU VAHEES THE
INCF O DONIONTISN I ALPE,CA N
AT
TYROCITHIK LE A EROFPE
CINKNGPP ANHAG ENAIAN. NA
>>
DIHA WT THEYHINKH WENUY O
NTHI OC INAN1 599?
DI THD EFIFOKNALCIS WOW HATOU Y
RETHNGOI E?ER
I>>N 1995
NODY HEDI 'NT.
TUD ANAC LYAL I AWSI ALTTLE
ERCO
NCD WHNWI  NETBA   CK
CABE E USIAH DJ TUSITWRD EDI
R
BE JNICENS BONHEOOK HE"T TH
F ADRE OE THSILK MOWRH "WCIH
THE THFA  OERF HTECEDR NIHSEE MI
SSOGE ILPRM,RA IIF RUG EDATTH
WAERTHE OOA S GCECHD AN HA TT,IY
WOLFSE, D ULBEI NTERRO TGAED
LLD PEED FROM HTE CO.TUNRY
DKHE TY WHWNO YOO U WERE?
L  KNEWATTS HAWI  ASA
R HOSCLAS O WHWAHET OUTRE SE
EKFOG ININN.ATRMIO
>>
YOUASID YUORE'M ARIERD.
>>O YOE HUAVLHCIENDR?
>> T.T NOYE
W YDOT ESSBR OUHUD ANDO ?>>
IS HE  A NECATRI LGENINE ER
ANINRKWOS LS I COINLVALEY DAN
HAEB ENI RNCIBED YLEPSUPORTIVE
S  TOFHITOJPRECYND A MEEC ARR.
Y
>>D SOUAILUYO EIV IN
SUNNYVAIGLE R IHTSIN LINCO
LLEY
CTOR CRE
T >>IEES LMS IKEERTH E ISSO
IBOMEDY BTHN ISLKOO GVIINN I
NN
SUALYVE.
TU I>>T UTEDRN OTHAT HEERAW S
RPA AADIC,OU Y KNWO, IN
KIN
ANHOG,N WOW N LISN
ALNNSUYV
MEH ,TIS I SEBSODY WHO
EENWH HL EIVD NINA IKN ING N1397
A WHEASTL IOLET BAY NDA H D
LU REEEDOT LEHTHP CE NHIESE
AS A W WOR AIKNG SA
AMPA
RTICED A HTET EIM.
SHEER INCOCINCDEE.>>
E N  ITHYOKBO K  TOUALT BAOUINTH
NNBEE GI TG INOFA HEROEP F
NKAG N NCIIDEHANT T5 T,7000 INNA
PEO.
>
O ES Y.
USATTH MTBET  EHUM OAITNN
SSMAACRE
ATECCOS RRTH
WAHA WT  ST?HTA
>> LLE,THWAET HHY AD DONE WAS
ADEYTH HPTK E TESTHE EN SOF
THNDSAS  OFIVCNSIAILI NH TESE
MPDANN THEE VTUENLYALF ARTE
EP
KEG TH HDEYDREATAND D
STED, EYT JUSW ETNUO  TNAD
ARSTCHD TEMANE INGUINNG TH M,E
LL
KIG
>>HAS T TATHE OSMTHA E RVE
ED
DIT ONTIME?
>> I THIM INKT YAAH VEE B.EN
W>>
AHT'OUS YER SNSEOF T  WHA
UL HADLE A BUMANNG O D O TH
D  KISIN OFHTI?NG
>> I HTINKHA TTE POLPE ERA UMH
MOREA C BLPAEO OFCMTG THSEE
TROATCIANS IETH WEOW DULT HINK
AND  YIFOU'RITCOE NDTNEIOD  O
LI
BEEVE ATTHYOHA WT OREU' D NIG
R TISHEHIGT TNIHIFG,  MOSHEOW F
T HECTAFO  MURDBER CS OME
LILY H AO  ONENHTET IW OULD BE
ISYEA,  ITHKN, TO NOCINV CE
TOPPELET HANOT ONLY WH ATU'YORE
N
DOROISG  WT, NGBU AHTT TISI
SA BONTIEDANGOY D DHT ATI T ISNC
NLE THOT RIY GHIHTNGY OU CAD NO.
H
>>UE AVYOLT AEDKT A ALLA BTUO
ATEDPPAENN IR NAW?DA
C >>ALLUTA Y INITHSB OOK IT M
S TIENONRWUSDAAN J TBRY,IEFL
I U
T  ULWODWYSA  AHTIA WS  LO
--INOKG IHE WN AS WL KOOING T
TH
ANEE WSTSOCCUNT F IELLIE I
REWA
S IV MWIENGL DARHCILVA
CUSNTA IAGN.
IE THSIMLA WTIRIESEER UHANTI NGT
ABIEORS MET OUWOHWOA H BDNEE
APREDO BYSIELDRS N ANDOW TH
'RE ING A TOCRRN YAN EMYE
LDAB'SER BANY D TEHSE
LATS MATHSOER WE AP FINOUL TME
W NEHR AEDINTHG EM BCEA SEUI
KENGEE SIAHE T SEM OSTRY OVE RPT
AN
AOVD ER INGA.
>>ELUO T AL TSO RYNIERH FE O A
WHMAWON TTOO  Y S HIDA'OWN TGIVE
HEAMALRE NOE R  WASRADPE NADI
CAMBRET MEX ERELYCATIHA WT  T WA
UBTYOL ADEUL  O.IT
WHTAS W I TTAHS EMOTH OF E
RATHS AT HEAPPD,NEE NVEUATY LL
ILRE WENERNB O ?
Y>>
S.
WEERTHE  REM ANYFALH AJAPNESE
HLFHA CE INESENILCHDRRON AS A
SULT  OFE THRAPE ADOENF O
EARSIISONSIE A TTTE HEIM,
UH,SM IT SA IDTATHH TE  REISLO
HOREWE TS SAUND FT ESHELDHICNREE
OG INSMDHETRET O AEDTH OR
OWD,B AEC USEEV RYFEW OMEN EDR
RELY WNTEI--D  M E,NA HTYE
CO
UL'T LE THSEE CILENDR.
BUVEU YOHA  TOENUDTARSND AHTT TH
A EYH - ITU MTHAVEB NEE A
TEHOLEIB COREIC FEST HN WOE ME
E. MTOAK
I K,AN GLLIINOUR WBA NBOR
RACHG INA ATD ILTHYUUC OLD
NEOVR LANDISUM' ARE L OT OFWOE
N ME'TULCODNA MKEHT  ATCHE,OIC
SO THT E AMSE IMTEREHETER WE   A
THDSUSANMEF  OWONO CMMINGTTI
TH
E ERUREWE UNCNOMED TEWO N
THNGWI TEHMVESEL INS TOE  RO
RI
RVE TODR W.N
>IW HONTESERVED TEHAYO FU NDOU
I AMS UPRR EDIST HTE  R
SPREON. SE
VE'SIT OMIWHREL.NG
S TMSE OMHT TAMOAL  T
EV'VNEYO IETAE LKDW HITIS
IN
RETESTEDND TY'RE SHOEDCK.
ONEYTH DW K'TNO ABOUHIT TS.
W>>HT DOY N'BOANWE AT UTII N
ITE THUNTE SEDTA
>>LEWL ,IS AMSU E --IWNDREI F
IT'SMA EYB DEMORAHIC YS,OU
OW, IT'S RAEYLL SNUTNING OT EM
TH
AT -I R ELALDOY  TN'KNO ETH
SW.
LAYBMAE IN OCKF RETEA, STM BYE
ERN'RWEEGHENT OU
INCHESJAE- ENEPASEERXPTS, UYO
R.EAPLSEM IE,MDIEAFELATY ER TETH
T, KOU WNO,HTE NUITSTD EES
GO,MERNNT SITELF, AWS ENAGG EDIN
OUA,  YOK NI,W NHT E
NSY IRPACHTHWI T AJNPAES OT CO
SR VEUPE OMOFH TIEOR WN, YO U
KN, SOMHOFE  TIER O
ALSOGSIN,  AHE TREER NMAY
POCATILE RASHYNS WO STME HING
LI>
T  WHATASW THA MONT IEHN ER
AT Y AKAED UTBOHW NE
. .DF.RD OW MUC 30 CSEDSON OF
ILMR 30 UMINTES OF FI?LM
>>0BEAY 3F E ETOFL FI M. M
HT R>>IG.
>>E Y.S
TH -- WEL,LA S UOYNK O ,WTHE
PJAHAESANE BD BEOMDT E U.S.S.
ANNAPEI ME DSOIAM ERNSCA DEDIS
S
RET OLTF HISOB MINBG. AN
JATHD E ESAPNEL EATONR T EIRD TO
E XC EUSBETH OMBGINBY A SYI,NG
WEASIT,  W  AOCLUDYAD OY  RWE LL
'TULCODN RAEYLLE SCE ELLYARHT AH
WISASNA  AEMRNICAP SHI UT --
>> WAT THEE PANBI YETH
WAY?>>
IT WAN A S GUOABT.
IT>> BAS W BOMD EBECEDEM 12,
19?
>> EYS.
AND,OUOK NW, ETHREE WRE
S
NEEE RL MEARABN ODAD N N OF
EM
TH- - BO HFO THMET OKO FO
OFAGOTE ET H JAPESANWSE OPOG
WNTOOSLMT  E DCKTOVELEL
OO
SHAT TA PSSRSGE.
T'DAN IARCS LEARO FM NEYNO HO W
K
LOHEATS  TOTF OHE AGT TTA HEJA
NESEOULE DSH ET EFLS AG
ERATTH WE PTEIANDNO T EHED KCO R
H
ELOR-  FIYNGVO HERD.EA
DH TE IDPRESTEN SEPCALIFIC
RETEQUESATTD HHT SI FOAOTGE BE
MOREBED FOWT I  ASSWNIN
ICAM
ERAT TANHES.ER
>>HWY?
>>LL WEC OULDN OLYS PLAECUTEON
EHE T RNSSAOYW H.
'SLYOBRABAE BCUY  TSEHE
DIDN WA
F NDKI OTTLEMAT ENTHEYT TH
WAO ED TWKEMA HJ APAN.
>>
'RW EOUE TF O MTIE. TH
IS  SIURES GUT OOKJ CA ETK
"THE RAPE OF NNKINGA "ND OUR
T U
ESS EEBN RIIS HAN